[Music]
on this thursday night troubling trend
the increase of infants and children
infected with covid and in the hospital
it can make parents to be very very
nervous plus if you can find one what's
the most effective way to use an at-home
rapid test the winter wallop on the west
coast the mess the misery and the mayhem
the american president's stern warning
on the anniversary of the capital riot
i'll allow no one to place a dagger at
the throat of democracy the concerns of
a donald trump comeback recording
controversy the world tennis champ not
feeling the love from australia's
government and lifesaver how a cat named
smuckers got a baby bobcat out of a
dangerous jam
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
as the omicron variant continues to
spread rapidly the impact is being felt
more widely testing capacity cannot keep
up and we don't have an accurate picture
of how many canadians now have coveted
and though the majority of people do
have mild symptoms the sheer number of
cases now means hospitalizations are
rising too quebec already has a record
number of people in hospital with covid
and the numbers are projected to keep
rising at a time when hospitals
everywhere are struggling with a lack of
staff
children generally have very mild
symptoms but there are cases of children
including infants ending up in the
hospital and even in icu toronto public
health confirmed today a child under the
age of four has died with covet 19. our
coverage begins with karen lieberman
we're seeing an uptick in newborns and
babies being admitted to the hospital in
ontario with the omicron variant
spreading rapidly the tiniest patients
with kovid 19 are being admitted to
hospitals across the country it can make
parents
parents to be very very nervous but i
think what people need to remember is
that if you actually get the vaccine in
pregnancy you can actually help protect
your baby in the first few months of
life an urgent push by pediatric
hospitals and physicians for pregnant
people to get vaccinated and quickly to
help protect infants at sickkids
hospital in toronto there are currently
16 pediatric patients with covid19
in the last few weeks children's
hospitals in ottawa and hamilton have
admitted a total of six babies under 12
months with the virus
newborns generally under the age of
three months or so
who have been admitted to hospital
and the common theme is that their
mothers had not been vaccinated for
covadine pregnancy a look at all recent
covid19 hospitalizations in ontario by
age group shows newborns up to children
aged four all those who are not yet
eligible for the vaccine have the
highest hospitalization rate among youth
meantime in the united states the number
of children hospitalized with covid19
is soaring we are indeed seeing
an absolute ton of cova 19 in children
at the current moment just this week the
u.s documented a record number of
pediatric hospital admissions related to
the virus
as many more children will get infected
a certain proportion of them
usually children that have underlying
comorbidities are going to wind up in
the hospital doctors say at least for
the youngest patients consider this
vaccination in pregnancy not only will
affect the mom
but might also produce antibodies which
can then go across and affect the baby
protection that could help for up to the
first six months of life karen lieberman
global news toronto
many canadians are unable to get tested
for covid tests are in such short supply
ontario's chief public health officer
said today testing is a luxury and said
if you have symptoms you should assume
you have cobit because it's so prevalent
and you should self-isolate if you can
get your hands on an at-home rapid test
there's a lot of debate right now about
whether it's best to swab your nose or
your throat some experts believe doing
both may better detect omicron as jamie
morocco reports like everything in this
pandemic advice on rapid tests is
evolving stephanie berry is a busy
mother of four so when she woke up with
a headache and a sore throat she quickly
reached for a rapid test so i did it up
my nose and it came back negative so i'm
like okay no big deal i went about my
day
um i got worse as the day progressed a
search online brought up throat swabbing
a common practice in the uk wipe the
soft tip of the swab around the back of
the throat i did throat like you know
the four or five times on your tongue
and then on your cheeks and then up my
nose five times and it came back
positive like within a minute a small
pre-print study out wednesday found
nasal rapid antigen tests leg when it
comes to catching covet early last month
a larger trial out of south africa
called nasal testing suboptimal when it
came to the omicron variant specifically
epidemiologist eric feigl ding says this
is likely because it replicates much
quicker in the upper respiratory tract
it's a very different virus from delta
and it seems that you can find it not
only more but also find it about a day
earlier
if you swab your mouth but officials
aren't ready to make formal
recommendations the us fda instead
issued a safety warning this week and
implored americans to follow their rapid
test kit instructions health canada
approves the inserts for at home rapid
tests here most advised nasal swabs and
while the public health agency wouldn't
say if it would be issuing new
guidelines toronto er doctor kashif
persona says the government needs to
make adjustments as the virus changes
it's time to be a bit more proactive
like every house should have a box of
these rapid tests your throat i think
should probably be standard now he says
swapping your throat and your nose
wouldn't invalidate the results just
make sure you're doing it correctly for
any mouth sampling do not drink or eat
about 30 minutes before you do the
sample barry is relieved she found she
was positive before her husband a
firefighter went to work and her kids
went to daycare i'm just like i'm
worried for how many people have
protected in their nose and then have
gone and done whatever thinking they're
negative the last thing any of us want
to unknowingly risk infecting others
jamie morocco global news toronto
well it was predicted and now it's
happening omicron is putting a strain on
health care in quebec new modeling
suggests within two weeks that province
could see more than 3 000 people
hospitalized in at least 400 in
intensive care both well above record
levels services are being reduced but
the province says it won't be enough to
free up the staff needed to care for the
expected influx of covid patients about
20 000 health care workers are off the
job right now in quebec because of covet
19.
quebec is bringing in new restrictions
that are targeting the unvaccinated
starting january 18th proof of
vaccination will be required to buy
alcohol in liquor stores and marijuana
in cannabis stores the province says
more restrictions are on the way
new modeling out of bc makes similar
projections the independent bc kovid 19
modeling group made up of experts from
bc universities and the private sector
projects between two and ten thousand
people could be in the hospital at one
time during the peak in late january the
group says there is evidence the variant
is less severe and could lead to shorter
hospital stays but with infections
doubling every three and a half days
hospitals could face a surge unlike
anything seen to date
more heavy snow has created headaches
across british columbia people living in
parts of that province that wouldn't
normally see much snow woke to find it
everywhere some love it others loathe it
as neethu garcia reports while it may
look like a winter wonderland it is
causing some extremely hazardous
conditions
it's the kind of snowfall some people in
surrey bc have never seen before this
year is lots of snow the winter wallop
leading to weather warnings for nearly
all of bc dumping up to 30 centimeters
of snow on some parts of vancouver
island and up to 20 centimeters on the
two and a half million who live in metro
vancouver most of whom just aren't used
to this it's beautiful unless you have
to drive in it we have to deal with a
lot less of it than the rest of canada
so
it could be worse
hydro outages plaguing the south coast
knocking out power to more than 20
thousand customers travel disruptions on
ferries and flights we do apologize
for the delays
temporary transit suspensions too with
this just the latest extreme weather for
bc which continues to step out of the
boundaries of what is normal in this
province according to climate change
expert john clegg we are experiencing
weather that more typically you'd see in
southern ontario and southern quebec
most school districts and university
campuses on the south coast canceled
classes thursday
all right we decided to get in on the
fun of a snow day ourselves
but these hills and mountains
all over bc that are the source of play
for so many of course also a sign of the
difficulty that drivers face in making
winter conditions perilous in this
province
we are told not to pull in the stops to
have lots of snow
a dangerous mix of freezing rain wind
and cold temperatures challenging snow
clearing operations like ice removal
from bridges and stretching city snow
removal resources thin a lot of people
out here don't have snow tires where the
rest of the country they all do it took
about 20 minutes for this bus to get
going again as already icy conditions
from earlier storms have only been made
worse and there's more snow on the way
and people are being told to avoid the
roads altogether if they can nito garcia
global news surrey bc
a cold snap is also lingering in other
parts of the country and there are
winter storm warnings across the
prairies the entire province of
saskatchewan is under an extreme cold
warning tonight temperatures are
expected to dip between minus 40 and
minus 50 with the wind chill and that
will extend to most of alberta and
manitoba too
south of the border parts of the u.s are
also grappling with severe winter
weather
in michigan storm warnings have been
extended to friday as blizzard
conditions pound that state reducing
visibility and making driving hazardous
over 30 centimeters of snow is expected
in some areas and another storm is
slamming kentucky and tennessee heavy
snow is snarling traffic there and
bringing highways to a standstill
a candlelight vigil at the u.s capitol
tonight one year since a violent mob
stormed inside encouraged by former
president trump it was an attack
intended to prevent joe biden from
assuming office
it failed but the threat to american
democracy persists today president biden
condemned those who stormed the capital
and those who instigated it behind the
scenes vowing to defend american
democracy and he delivered a searing
message targeted at donald trump and his
supporters
you can't love your country only when
you
win you can't obey the law only when
it's convenient
you can't be patriotic when you embrace
and enable lies
our washington bureau chief jackson
proskow covered that day and reports on
the message delivered a year later in a
country more divided than ever
i'm praying that we'll never have
another day like we had
a year ago today
inside the very building overtaken by
the mob president joe biden offered a
sharp rebuke of the lie that incited the
attack the former president of the
united states of america
has created and spread a web of lies
about the 2020 election
he's done so because he values power
over principle
because he sees his own interest
as more important than his country's
interest than america's interests
without naming donald trump biden warned
about america's path toward autocracy
that future elections risk being
overturned by politicians who ignore the
will of voters i will stand in this
breach
i will defend this nation
not allow no one to place a dagger at
the throat of democracy you'll never
take back our country with weakness you
have to show strength and you have to be
strong
when the rioters marched in trump's name
last january they aimed to overturn
biden's victory
their targets the lawmakers who barely
escaped still relive the horror of that
day a police officer in a big flak
jacket and a large rifle grabbed me
firmly by the collar like this
i'll never forget that grip
and said to me senator we've got to get
out of here
you're in danger
yet one year later americans do not have
a shared sense of what happened on
january 6th trump supporters have tried
to downplay the events or laud what they
believe was a justified action
in their memory during a moment of
silence for the police officers who died
during the siege only two republicans
were present liz chaney and her father
former vice president dick cheney it
matters that you have two different
realities playing out both online and
offline that people don't see the same
facts the way they are seamus hughes
researches violent extremism in america
he warns the lies and division have made
january 6 the rallying cry for future
political violence if we can't call a
speed of spade that's going to be an
issue not only for for now but in future
events
jackson there are people who think
donald trump could run for president
again in 2024 how might the events of
one year ago factor into that election
well donna it's so incredibly polarizing
that both parties are seizing upon the
events of that day democrats say it's a
reason to pass voting rights legislation
republicans say it's a reason why
elected official officials should have
the ability to toss out election results
if they suspect fraud either way
republican voters are still firmly on
the side of donald trump 60 say he bears
little to no responsibility for the
violent events of that day
donna
all right jackson prosco in washington
thanks
some brighter news in canadian politics
the federal leader of the ndp is a new
father jagmeet singh and his wife
welcomed their new daughter on monday a
day after singh's own birthday and he
tweeted today our powerful little baby
girl is basically my birthday present
for life
the uprising in kazakhstan turns deadly
coming up the president is pointing the
finger at international terrorists
[Music]
in kazakhstan police say they've killed
dozens of what they call anti-government
rioters in almaty the country's most
populated city a state of emergency is
in effect these protests began over
rising fuel prices and then escalated
and now troops from russia have arrived
as redmond shannon reports the kazakh
president claims foreign trained
terrorists are responsible for the
unrest
after days of containing protests and
riots kazakh security forces hit back
with deadly force police will only say
they killed dozens of people who were
trying to storm government buildings in
the main city 18 security force members
have also reportedly died the government
says more than two thousand people have
been arrested this is some of the
aftermath of days of violence sparked
initially by rising fuel costs including
a presidential residence and the mayor's
office building in almaty
international armed forces arrived on
the ground thursday at the invitation of
kazakh president kasim jomar tokyo the
troops are from an alliance of former
soviet republics primarily russia what
role they will play and how long they
will stay is unclear
tokyo claims the root of the violence
also lies outside of kazakhstan saying
international terrorists have trained
protesters it's a very much a big
concern that people do want
mandatory to stop a cell to tumble is a
kazak political academic she says many
people in the country believe the
protest movement has been deliberately
sabotaged by organized groups causing
violence hastening a crackdown are they
affiliated with the government are they
mafia people
are they
indeed the foreign troops who are
trained and and engaged in this type of
things activities that's not really
clear tutumlu says even if protests are
quelled for now they will resume unless
there is real political reform
as this protester put it the coiled
spring has been unleashed after 30 years
redmond shannon global news london
ahead why two cats now share a special
bond
[Music]
food prices around the world hit a
10-year high last year and the un food
and agriculture organization which
tracks globally traded food commodities
says there's little relief in sight for
2022. prices were up more than 28
percent the highest spike was maize up
44 percent food prices eased slightly in
december but that dip followed four
consecutive months of increasing costs
the food agency says the global pandemic
uncertain climate conditions and rising
prices for producers leave little room
for optimism for a more stable market
this year
well i know cat stories can't wipe away
all the bad news but we need some
optimism right so here's a little tale
about a domestic cat from a shelter who
saved a wild bobcat kitten
smuckers is the cat his blood turned out
to be a match for a bobcat kitten it was
found in a new brunswick barn weak cold
and dehydrated the transfusion worked
the bobcat is doing better and smuckers
who arrived at the fredericton spca days
ago is being called a hero and has
already been adopted
two happy cats
no entry for novak djokovic next the
tennis stars match against australia's
vaccine laws
a big tennis star has discovered his
fame can't protect him novak djokovic is
stuck in a quarantine hotel in australia
and he could be deported his hopes of
playing in the australian open hang in
the balance and there's a big debate
about whether it's fair eric sorenson
explains
it's believed the world's top tennis
player was brought in this van to this
hotel out of sight and out of the
australian open novak djokovic had
posted heading down under with exemption
permission but from local authorities
only and the australian government found
no proper medical exemption nor
apparently evidence of djokovic being
vaccinated if you have a visa and you're
double vaccinated well you're very very
welcome to come but if you're not double
vaccinated
and you're not an australian resident or
citizen
well you can't come
djokovic who all but owns the australian
open trophy now awaits a court to decide
whether to let him stay and compete or
be deported
in djokovic's native serbia it's verging
on a diplomatic incident the president
has decried australia's decision and
djokovic's father declared serbia's
salvation at stake
[Applause]
his fans call it discrimination just
because he chooses not to state
you know his civic status i mean it is a
personal choice but others in the tennis
community say djokovic made his choice
and could not finesse his way into a
country that has imposed tough rules to
combat kovid i feel
sorry for him
but at the same time
he know he knew the conditions since
a lot of months ago so
he makes his own decision this
tournament was an opportunity for
djokovic to be acclaimed the greatest of
all time by one important metric grand
slam titles djokovic rafael nadal and
roger federer have each won 20 a
remarkable moment in tennis history and
djokovic could break the deadlock
winning the open he has swept a record
nine times but like basketball's kyrie
irving and football's aaron rodgers
djokovic has now attracted followers
among the unvaccinated and sidestepping
the rules could risk the integrity of
both the sport and australia's laws the
message that's being sent is a strong
one here first of all athletes are not
the exception allowed to be treated
differently from the rest of society
when it comes to a pandemic or health
risks djokovic's potential absence
leaves an opening for dennis shapovalov
and felix oj aliasim canadians who just
pulled off major victories in a team
event in australia and like most tennis
fans will want the australian open to
make headlines on the courts and not in
the courts eric sorensen global news
toronto
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is edmonton's walter dale
bridge thanks for watching hope to see
you here again tomorrow take care of
yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you